このディッティジュ・カンムでは
この建築 建築じゃなくて建築ではね
あの 心っていうのは あの
やっぱり汚れちゃうし
邪見に陥っちゃうし で
もし自分がわずかに仏教のことを知ってるんだと
まあ経には行ってるんだと
そこである人がすごい強力に
ものすごい迫力があって
違う宗教のがあんた知ってますか？あの人はまあこういう奇跡を起こしてますよって言っちゃったら
なんとなく自分がもう圧倒されちゃって
じゃあ行きましょうって行っちゃうで
行ける 行ってしまうんですね
心っていうのはそういうふうなものなんですね
奇跡を起こしてますからと
なんとか言ったら ですから
このきちんと真理を聞き直して聞き直して見返しておかないと
もう弱くなってしまう
ですから この正見のためにこの徳行を必要なんです
そこでまあ それは悪行と善行はありますと
悪行の心はにありまして
善行の心は善行為の心は八ありますから
全部種類ですね で終わりましたと
そこでですね どこで止まりますかね
まああの色界と無色界のことを言って
あのちょっと休みに入ります
で 色界の禅定っていうのはもう別に簡単なことなんですね
ルーパ・チャトゥック・シランパナ・マノー・カンマン・エーワ・パンチャ・バーワナ・ナミャ
色界っていうのはこの瞑想することですから
それは確実にマノー・カンマン
何でしたっけ？マノー・カンマンっていうのは
囲碁ですね で 心でしなくちゃいけない
バーワナだから アッパナー・パッタン・ジャーナンガ・ベヘッデーナ・パンチャ・ヴィダン・ホーティ
で あのアッパナー・パッタンというあの暗示状態にならなくちゃいけないんですね
なんか例えば第二禅定に似ている近侍禅定ですか
近侍禅定なんか生まれてもすぐ壊れちゃうんですね
ですから暗示行という
このきちんと禅定に入って
それを身について止まれるという状態までやらなくちゃいけない
そうするとそのレベルに心が上達する
ですから禅定はこの色界ではつありますね
それは全部囲碁なんです
で アルーパというのは無色界
色の禅定終わった人は無色禅定を作らなくちゃいけない
それもつあります それもマノー・カンマン
囲碁なんですね まあそれで全ての善行為は終わり
じゃあちょっとお休みします
分ぐらい まあこちらチャートを持ってますね
そこを見れば楽に勉強できます
じゃああののカーマーヴァチャラ・カンマ・パーカッターン
カーマーヴァチャラ・カンマっていうのは欲求の欲界の業ですね
欲界っていうのはこの体を持ってる生命の次元で
地獄と人間と天国っていうのは欲界と呼ぶんです
で そこにそこら辺に生まれ変わる業が欲界業と呼ぶし
欲界業は心から見れば全部の心なんですね
で こちら あるでしょうですね
この最後のこのテキストからからページまでのこと
このチャートがございますから
で この高井さんに感謝するなりにケーキ買ってあげるなりに何とかしてあげないと
で からまではこの不善の不善心ですね
それからから かな これ危ない
もう人がそこでチャートだから
いきなり あ そうそう クサラと書いてますからね
三十一から三十八まで欲界の善心ですね
そこで十二とこの八がまとめたら二十になっちゃう
二十善心が生まれるんですね
欲界では そこで結果なんですけど
悪いことをしたらどこに生まれ変わるかと
例えばこの上 一から十二までの不善心があるでしょ
その不善心をした人に結果として熟心が生まれるんですね
不善熟心が 不善熟心が七つしかないんです
十三から十九まで それは不善熟心ですね
だから不善心と不善熟心全部計算すると全部十九種類
不善心だけは十二と熟心は七つと
その中でエッタ アクサラ カンマ ウッダッチラヒタン アパーエブーミアン パティサンディン ジャニエティ
アパーエブーミ アパーエっていうのはまあ簡単に地獄だとね
こっちリセン リゼンチと書いてますからね
いいとこか良いところから離れたものというふうな
地獄に生まれるの 生まれる場合は
この十二の中で十一種類の心なんですね
十二番目のウペッカー サハガタン ウッダッチ サンパユッタンという心ででは地獄には落ちません
貪瞋心で悪いことをしちゃったら地獄に行く可能性もあるし
瞋恨心二つで怒りで悪いことをしちゃったら地獄に行く可能性はあるし
それで痴根心で見切りっちゃう疑いですか
偽装 この疑いを持ったら
それはもう邪見につながりますからね
で 地獄に落ちる可能性はあります
で 掉挙ではもう別に消性はしないんだと
ここで考えているのは
掉挙という心自体が弱いんだと
掉挙というのは混乱状態だからね
なんかまあ混沌状態 混乱状態でもうはっきりしっかりしない状態ですね
まあわかりやすく言えばこの睡眠状態ですね
睡眠じゃなくて これなんていうのはその状態
このドロゥシンと英語で言うんだけど
あの眠 え？眠気状態 眠
もう眠気でまあなんかわけのわからない状態
そのぐらいの状態だから
たまたまみんなね 混乱してたりするし
その場合はほとんど行動不能なんですね
例えば子供が一生懸命稽古して
まあ発表会しようかなと思ったら
舞台に行ったところですぐいきなりね
神経質になっちゃったところで
もう何もできなくなっちゃうんですね
その時は当然 何て言いますか
情動の心なんですね せっかく一応ね
稽古したのに 突然もう人をみんな見ちゃったら
大人がいっぱい見てしまっちゃったら
もう情動の心が生まれちゃう
その場合は何も行動できなくなる
ただそれだけ ということは
心が体を動かすまでは強くないんです
情動の心は 心は弱いということで
で 大人にもそういう情動心っていうのは結構生まれますけど
情動の心生まれちゃったら
やっぱりどこにいるか
何やってるかということもわからなくなっちゃう
だからって悪いことをしようともしないんで
その場合は 何もできません
ただショック受けただけ
で こちらのリストではこの何番目
十二番目ですね 情動の心
そこで悪いことをした人が
まあ地獄とやらね あの
楽がない世界に生まれ変わる場合は
この一から十一の心の結果として生まれ変われる
そこでこの生まれ変われる場合はどんな心で生まれ変わるかというと
この十九番目のウペッカーサハガタン・サンティールナ・チッタンということがあるんです
随動心 この随動心で生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
ですから 有分心も結生心も死心も
えーと この随動心ですね
次にこのテキストで言っているのは
それは生まれる時 結生の心
結生の心は随動心だけ
で まあ違う言葉で言うならば
情動の心生まれたっても地獄には落ちませんと
ということなんです で
何も行動できない弱い状態だからね
でも業にはなります 悪業にはなります
情動の心は そこで生まれ変わってからも人々に
あのー 悪いカルマが結果出すんですね
あのー 何カルマですかっけ
それは このウパッタンバとウパピーラとサポートの
えーと サポートするカルマと
支持業と妨害業 支持業と妨害業ともう一つあります
あの 殺害業 その三つとして生まれてから機能する可能性あります
例えば人が 人間で人が生まれたら
その人を 生まれてから他の業が出てきて支持する
その場合はより幸福になる
たまたま あのー チャンスに恵まれるとかね
で 妨害業入ったら たまたまひどい目に遭ったり
ダマになったりとかね
チャンス逃したりとかはするし
殺害業が入っちゃったら
もういきなり人が死んでしまったりする
寿命終わる前に そういうふうにこの後から業がついてきて結果が出す
因縁 心が生まれて結果が出すんですね
それでこので 欲界でも色界でも
この悪いことをしたならば追ってきて悪い結果出す可能性あるんだと
わかりますか？言ってること
こういうことなんですね
生まれ変わる場合はもう地獄に生まれ変われます
その場合はたった一つの心で生まれ変われます
水道心で 十二の不善心
全部生まれ変わることはしません
十二の不善心 全部生まれ変わる可能性
働きはしません 十一種類だけ
一つは何もできない そこで生まれ変わってからサポートするなりに妨害するなりに
その人を殺すなりに この後生まれてからはもう十二の不善心も行動するんだと
十二の不善心には七種類の意地悪心があります
ですから七種類の意地悪心が働いています
ということは 色界っていうのは梵天なんですね
瞑想してせっかく梵天に生まれても
悪い業が来て なんか邪魔したりする可能性はあるということなんです
どういうことかというと
梵天に生まれ変わったら眼識があります
耳識があります それから何でしたっけ？それ二つかな
三つない 鼻 舌 身はないんですね
梵天には耳識はない 舌の意識はないし
体の意識もないんですね
で 見える 聞こえるだけ
それから心は働いています
心は強力に働いています
ですから こちらにあるんでしょう
あの不善心の意地悪心の場合はウペッカーサハガタン・チャック・ウィンヤーナン
ウペッカーサハガタン・ソータ・ウィンヤーナンというものは
その二つが邪魔する可能性あります
いわゆる聞きたくない
聞いて面白くない音を聞くようになるとか
それから見て面白くないとね
見たくないものは見えたりする可能性あります
梵天にいても でも梵天だから体の感覚ないんだから
痛みとかね 触れたくないものに触れたとかね
はないんです 嗅ぎたくない
ひどい臭いが嗅いでしまったとか
それもない 美味しくないものを食べて食べてしまったとかね
それもない もう食べるということはしない
梵天は そこはないんだけど
二つ持ってますから 目と耳
そちらから悪いカルマが妨害業として
妨害とは言いませんだけど
機能する可能性あります
で 殺害業はないと思いますけどね
梵天には 殺害業はもう不可能だと思います
寿命が終わるまでいられるんです
殺害業をしたければ一つの方法なんですけど
この梵天にいる梵天が自分でさらに瞑想すると
さらに瞑想して高いレベルの瞑想善業を作っちゃえば
その業が殺害するかもしれません
その人 禅定が高いレベルの禅定が
そこでその人は殺害して人や梵天を殺害して
もう高い梵天に生まれてしまっちゃうという可能性はあります
だからだから殺害業はいつでも悪いわけじゃないんです
で 動物がね すごい苦労しているんだと
普通だったらもう年寿命あるんだけど
まあ年で早くも死んでしまったということは
どうか それはいいことだと言った方がよろしいんです
で あの善行為は殺害します
善も で ストーリーで言うならば何でしょうかね
マリカ夫人ですか こんな本当のストーリーかどうか分かりませんだけど
ものすごい徳を積んだコーサラ王様の后で
もう想像できないほどの布施を積んだ人なんですけど
死ぬ時 死ぬ瞬間でちょっと心が悪くなっちゃって
自分がした悪いことを思い出しちゃって
地獄に落ちちゃったんですね
であれほどお釈迦様にお釈迦様が会えたこの一番大きなお布施行事も
マリカ夫人のもう考え方でマネージャーでやったものなんですね
で 地獄に落ちたところでもう 1週間いたんだと
で すぐ後で自分で気づいちゃったんですね
なんで自分が地獄にいるんですかと
それ気づくためには もうちょっと 1週間かかったかもしれません
大体地獄に落ちるのはもうサンティラニッティタですし
で 心は弱いしね で 過去を思い出すことはちょっと時間かかっちゃったんですけど
で 思い出した自分がもうお釈迦様にあってお釈迦様とすごい仲良しで
これぐらい修行したり
戒律守ったり もうお布施したり
すごいやっていたんではないかと
すぐもう自分もやってきた行動ですか
お釈迦様に会ったこととかもすぐ思い浮かんだんです
思い浮かんだんですね
なんでこっちにいるんですかと
その瞬間で そこで死んじゃったんです
地獄から地獄で死んじゃって
もうさっと天国に生まれ変わったんですね
それには七日間 人間の世界では七日間行ったんだけど
その地獄の次元では まあほんの瞬間かもしれませんしね
時間関係っていうのは
そのその次元によってね
変わりますから もういつでも私は言うことだから
我々にとっては歳 百年というのはずいぶん長い時間ですけど
ゴキブリにはまあ 1ヶ月間っていうのはずいぶん同じく同じ感覚なんです
ハエには 1週間っていうのは同じ気持ちなんです
我々の百年と同じなんです
ですから その時間関係っていうのはそんなにものでね
そんなに計算する必要もないもので
とにかく彼女が天国に生まれ変わったんです
そこで王様がどこに生まれ変わったかと聞きたくて聞きたくているんですけど
毎日お寺に行くんだけど
お釈迦様は他のことを一生懸命喋ったりして聞けないようにするんです
聞けないように でお釈迦様は知ってるんです
もう死ぬ瞬間で心が悪くなったと
そこでマリカ夫人は他の人と比べないほど徳を積んだんだから
今地獄にいるんだよと言えないでしょうし
立場上は ですから 王様がもう今随分お気に入りだからね
あの人がね で 行って今日は聞きますと
お釈迦様にとって話 話の途中でまあお釈迦様はいろいろ話をする
それで時間になって帰ると
ああ 忘れちゃった 明日聞きますと言って
また明日も行くと そこで 1週間になったところで
もう一応お釈迦様もそういう他の話を一応抑えたところで
実はもう 1週間も来たんだけど
この聞き忘れたんだと
マリカがもう亡くなったんだけど
今どこにいるんですか？と言ったら
まあ彼女はですねと卒園にいるんだと
と場所と名前を言うんですね
あそこでこういう名前でいるんだと言ったら
王様 彼女が天国に行かないならば
誰が天国に行けるんですか？というふうにまあ自慢して帰ったそうで
それでまあ無事問題解決しましたと
とにかくそのストーリーでから計算できるのは
殺害業は善行為もするということなんです
で 人間の場合は殺害業は不善行為なんです
人間に生まれるためには
善を行っていないと人間に生まれません
だからいいことをしたんだから
我々は過去で今人間になってるんです
そこで早く死んでしまったならば
それはあくまでも不善行為の結果なんです
天国に早く寿命が終わっちゃったら
それもあの不善行為なんです
殺害業 地獄の場合は殺害業もやっぱり善行為になる可能性も不善行為になる可能性もある
例えば人が死んじゃって
まあちょっと上の方の地獄に落ちたんだと
そこでなんで私はここにいるんだなと思ったら
自分がやったいろんな悪いことあるでしょうし
思い浮かんだら 私はあんなひどいことを言って
こんなひどいことをやったなって
もっとひどいカルマが思い浮かんじゃったら
そこで殺されてもっと低い地獄に
もっとレベル低い地獄に落ちる可能性もあります
天界ではなんかある次元がある
神々の次元がありまして
あの嫉妬したりするみたいですね
他の人のこと嫉妬しちゃったら死ぬと
死んじゃうんです 体がもう霊だからね
もう体すごくそんなにきつい体ではないんですね
それで自分よりすっごい堂々たる力強くて輝いている神々を見て
ああ この連中はって思ったら
あの怒りのエネルギーが生まれたら
そこで自分の寿命はそれで終わり
死んでしまう その場合も殺害業なんです
嫉妬するして死ぬ神々いて
怒って死ぬ神々もいると
ずっといろんな楽しく遊んだりしているのは
まあ神々の生き方だから
もし何かって怒ったら
まあそれで死んでしまう
天国も結構危ないところなんです
せっかく行っても まあ嫉妬する
怒る癖があったら まあ行かん方がいいかも
人間はいくらか硬い体持ってますから
まあまあ怒っただけで嫉妬しただけでは死にませんだけど
人間も強力に怒りの感情
嫉妬の感情が生まれたら死には至るんです
死ぬかそれほどの苦しみが生まれることはあり得るんです
そういうことで 梵天に生まれても悪いカルマがもう妨害業としてついてくる
人間で生まれても過去の悪い業が妨害業としてついてくる
そこで妨害業としてついてくる場合は
七つの意地悪心が全部生まれるんです
七つっていうのはどこからどこ
十三から十九までの七つの心が生まれる
でくる そこでこのカルマが見ると
この心を見てください
十三から十九まで チャック
ウペッカー サハガタン
チャックインヤーナン
ソートインヤーナンだから日本語訳もありますね
あの 色具の眼識 耳識 鼻識
舌識 身識ですね ということは
我々の人生を見ると 見たくないものを見たりするでしょうに
いつでも見て気持ち悪くなったと
あれは見たくないものはいくらでも見てるでしょうね
聞きたくない音をいくらでも聞いているでしょうね
夜寝ていると猫たちがね
もう音楽を始めたら聞きたくはないでしょうし
隣にね 暴走族がね オートバイに乗ってあっちこっち行ったり来たりすると
それを聞きたいんですかね
聞きたくはないし それですっごくストレス溜まっちゃうわ
神経はもうイカれちゃうわ
そういうのは自分の悪い過去の悪い業の結果なんです
その時結果が出してるんです
だから耳があるのはカルマの結果だからしょうがないんです
それであのすごいカルマ
いいカルマの方が強い人にとっては
そういうのはね あまり気にしない
雑音とか雑音とかね 別に気にしないで平気でいられるし
それでカルマが弱い人のこと
なんかこのアメリカの女性なんですけど
テレビで見たんだけど
あの電波アレルギーなんですね
そういうことっていうのはなかなか生きづらいんですね
ですから その旦那さんがもう全然電波とかなんとかとか
この電線とかね かなりもうない低い田舎に家を建てて
この特別にこの電気 それでも必要でしょうに
ですから全部この何重も
あの 何て言いますか 覆って
この特別に電線を全部引いて
この電波があの電波というんで
その電波じゃないんですね
あの電磁波とか何とかが届かないようにと
全部カバー カバー カバーして
もう家を作ってるんだと
だから大変苦しいんですね
生き方はね その方にとっては人間で生まれたんだけど
もうそれぐらい家建ててくれるんだ
くれる旦那がいるということはね
まあ過去で結構いいカルマがついたということでもありますけど
同時にあの悪いカルマはまあ影響を与えているんですね
そこでまたこの現代 この現代的な汚染
依存汚染 いろいろあるでしょうね
それはすぐ効く人もいて
効かない人もいるし ご飯食べられない人がいる
卵を食べられない人がいるしね
で 小麦粉を食べられない人々がいるし
だからその人々はもういろいろ苦労しなくちゃいけない
そういうのはもう何のことなく
もうアビダンマから見ればその人の業なんです
そういうのはあの妨害業
人間で徳を積んだんだから生まれたんだけど
妨害業がついてきて 体をいじめる
目をいじめる 鼻をいじめる
舌をいじめると 耳をいじめる
ということにはなります
で 妨害業だから妨げることもできます
だから生まれた業がもうどうしようもないんです
生まれここ 今世で生まれた業はもう決まっているんだから
死ぬまでの寿命とかね
まあそこは決まっているんだから
それは変化もう何もできません
で カルマが消えたら死ぬ
後からついてくるものは我々にはコントロールできます
ですから そこら辺はコントロールできます
妨害業ではなくて 指示業が入るようにいろいろ工夫したりとかね
ですからその生まれつきアレルギーの人々はもう治りますよ
何のこともなく治ろうと思えば
その人々はやっぱりこの環境を変えるということでは治りません
治りませんか まあそれも障害というか
症状が出ないかもしれませんだけど
それよりはやっぱり心をきちんと育てる心はずっと明るい思考で持つと
特に慈悲の瞑想を徹底的にするとかね
慈悲の気持ちを随分思い
その分心に育ててみると
妨害業は出てこないんです
その代わりに指示業がついてくる
妨害業を抑えると指示業がついてきます
だから何のことなくアレルギーなんかを消えちゃうんです
大体子供のアレルギーっていうのは
まあ大体は大人になってくると治るんです
治る場合がありますね
それも同じこと 子供は心が弱いんだだから泣きっぱなしでわがままで
だから心を育てませんね
それで大人になってくると
独立して自分で生活しなくちゃいけないことになってくるし
それで自分で全部やらなくちゃいけないんだ
そうすると泣きっぱなしはダメで
わがままだったら何もやられなくなっちゃうし
そういうことで本人がしっかりしようと
みんなと仲良くしようではないかと
というふうに この自分の意思で明るく行動することに決めちゃえば
大体のどんな子供でも大人になると
そういうふうに自分でもう道を決めちゃいますからね
それで結構もうアレルギーは消えちゃうんですね
それも心が変わりますからね
もし大人になっても弱い心のままだったら
もう大人になってもそのアレルギーは消えません
ですから アレルギー対策法っていうのは
やっぱりもう慈悲の瞑想なんですね
そこでもう一つアレルギーあります
この皮膚病とかね ずっと体が痒くて痒くて
まあどうしようもないとかね
ああいうのは嫉妬から生まれるんです
過去で嫉妬したんですから
そこは空いてるんですね
ですから その人々は嫉妬の反対の慈悲喜捨の喜を瞑想しなくちゃいけないんです
瞑想と それから布施もしなくちゃいけない
布施も人を喜ば喜ぶものをしなくちゃいけない
そうやっていると心が変わって治るんです
で このストーリーがあるんです
それには アンルッダ尊者だと思いますけど
これ釈迦族のお釈迦様の親戚なんです
で お釈迦様の兄弟ですけど
義理のね で 出家したし
阿羅漢になりましたし
で そのアンルッダ尊者がもうお釈迦様はあまり自分の家に戻れませんでしたからね
なかなか で 自分の家に行ったんですね
行ったら家というのはもう釈迦族だから
もうオケの人々でもかなり贅沢ができるし
で 自分の家に行ったら
このうちの人々は盛大にこのアンルッダ尊者にこのお布施したりはしたんだそうです
でも自分の妹はなかなか出てこない
で 人の前に出てこない
だからこのアンルッダ尊者がもう兄貴だから
で 全部行事なんか終わって
妹はどうです？どこですか？と言ったら
もう彼女は全然人の前には出ませんと
何ですか？と聞いたら
まあひどい皮膚病 で 人に顔を見せたくないんです
すっごく痛くて もう痒くて痛くて
もうどうしようもなくて
このベッドなんかに薬ずっと巻いて巻いて
この薬の上でもういつでもいるような感じで
だから出られないんです
そう聞いたら もうじゃあ自分で行ってみてみますと
だからまあ自分の妹だからね
人に顔を見せなくなってもしょうがないんだけど
行ってみたらすごい残酷な状態で
で アナグルトサンガっていうのはこの神通力すごいあるんです
で 過去を見たんです なんで自分の妹こうなったかといったら
もう昔がもうかなり悪いことをしたことが思い出して
もう嫉妬のことをしてね
この業が今働いているんだと
言ったら じゃあもうそのことで
じゃあなんとか言いますか
解決方法を言いますよと言って
で あなたのね 財産ありますから
それをね ケチをしないで全部使って大きな御寺作りなさいと
お坊さんたちに住むような僧堂
すごい立派に贅沢に作りなさい
作って寄付したらそこは治りますよと
全部 言ったらまあシャカ族の人々っていうのはすごい仏教に対してはもうものすごい信仰
すごい強いんですね なぜならば
それは社会的な現象もありましたし
このバラモン人を抑えようというすごいシャトゥリ諸族が
この王家の人々はね バラモン人がこの権力を握っていたんだからね
政治はシャトゥリ諸族やってるし
ですから宗教家だと 自分たちが神の子だと言ってるし
そこでシャトゥリ諸族から宗教家が出てくると
みんな喜んじゃったんだよ
だから六師弟という仏教で言ってる人いたでしょ
みんなシャトゥリ諸族なんです
バラモン人は一人もいないんです
ですから インドで結構認められて
王様たちに認められたし
お釈迦様がものすごい抜群にもう正真正銘のブッダになりましたから
これも大変認められるってことは当たり前なんです
そういうことで このロヒニという女性の名前ロヒニでしたけどね
彼女がまあ言われたんだから
もう何のこともなく もうかなりの素晴らしい建物を造って
大変贅沢な建物を作って
お坊さんたちに寄付をしたんです
作り始めた時からどんどんどんどん皮膚病を治って
寄付をする行事の時は
彼女は元の銀色の顔に皮膚に戻って
美しい体でこのお布施行事に参加しましたと
すごい美しく輝いている体で
で このカルマの働きっていうのは
彼女は過去生でね あの誰かの旦那さんの奥さんになっちゃって
二人なんで 奥さんたちが
そこでもう一人の奥さんのことはなんか嫉妬して
あのベッドにあの向こうであの小さな植物があります
あの植物の葉っぱ体に触れたら
わずかでも触れたらすぐ腫れちゃうんです
痒くて痒くて もう四時間
五時間も痒いんです 膨らんで腫れるんです
葉っぱは小さいんですけど
つるなんです だから間違ってでもあっちこっち歩くと
足にでもちょっとでも触れちゃったら
もう知らない人がヘビに噛まれただろうと思うんです
それぐらいもうヘビに噛まれたぐらい
誰かに噛まれた時より痛いんです
一旦それから膨らんで腫れてきて
もう痒い痒い痒い 痒いところじゃないんです
あれは もう痒みだっていうのは
掻けば気持ちいいでしょうに
そんなもんじゃない もうものすごい強烈なんです
その葉っぱをもう干しても同じなんです
干して粉にして シートの下に撒いておいた
それで彼女は寝たところで体中痒くなって
もう醜くなっちゃって
まあまあ それでもどうしようもないでしょうに
だからそういうことをしたんだから
彼女はそういう業でもう苦労したんだと
その時も業害業でこの業が働いてきたんです
ですから 逆の行為をさせたんですね
いい観測を付勢しますと
悪い観測をあげたことで悪い結果が受けたんだから
じゃあいい観測 観測というんです
感覚という体のね お坊さんたちがもう冬であろうが夏であろうが
もう暑くない 寒くない建物で寝泊まりできて
修行できて そういう立派な建物を作らせたんです
それは気に込めかえ指示をアナグルトサンガは教えてあげたんです
業の働きを知ってるんだから
そういうことで このもうたまたま見えますけどね
そういう体のね 病気の皮膚のね
もう大変皮膚が腫れて
腫れるところじゃない
本当にすごい悲しくなっちゃいます
見るとね でもそういう人々はやっぱり自利利他の喜の瞑想と
それなりの人々喜ぶ行為をしてあげると
嫉妬の業のカルマが消えるんです